are you hanging up Court tickets for the
victory it's that time [__] open
that door we got no lady I don't know
what's going on in just this is Black
Sabbath
[Music]
there's no way he'll oh [__] we're back
[__] we'll do the podcast was
supposed to do last night
we got so hard we just had here talking
[__] out you understand me but we're
back like chlamydia to tell you that
[__] and know the fear uncle Joey's here
look at that huh
we [__] around tonight we got a
little sky [__] dive or whatever this
is take a look at these bugs look at the
wings on this look at that little [__]
you think you're dealing with tonight
last night we had two tonight we had a
third one and a little chocolate for
dessert on top just to meet Lee squirm a
little bit just to let him know what the
[__] is really crack-a-lackin' he's
Israeli have time to [__] squirm the
only person that should be squirming
right now are the North Koreans I'm
saying there's people swimming there
right now there's a whole [__]
battalion going underwater on that way
the Korea that's me [__] when
you wake up tomorrow two things are
gonna be different the dare dream
program it's over it's over
you [__] better start dreaming
a chariot to take you back to your
original country that includes me and
six months I'll be gone too
I didn't give no information I'm not
that stupid I [__] put him on the
gold chase and [__] I have them going to
Arizona and Texas looking for me you
know I don't [__] around number two it's
gonna be the 4th of July in Korea what's
left of it trust me I'm telling you and
you're gonna enjoy it and love it shut
your mouth you liberal [__] it's time
to bomb a [__] and let us know
what's crack-a-lackin' when there's
blood that's changed
always remember that remember that time
you spoke to that doing he backhanded
you broke your lip you never talk to
that [__] again did you cuz
there was change anyway enough is enough
it's time to smoke the [__] [__] that
killed the guitar player from Steely Dan
and I'm sayin this is the [__] right
here peg
it will come back to you look at that
what slow and [__] heat from banana
bread tonight in every clear this this
is Det tonight this is transmission
fluid from the trucks the narcos used in
nineteen [__] 94 the transport blow
from colleague the [__] Bogota there's
the actual transmission fluid Pablo
whatever his name is Francisco Escobar
had in his [__] truck right here with
him listen we ain't [__] around till
that you understand me if you're feeling
a little off if your [__] hurts go
what's up my Netflix or something go
[__] watch with your wife
we're gonna watch what I'm for an HBO
that's great that's great that's great
[__] was how we do it tonight
young Sam edibles [__] reefer that
kills people and straight-up [__] love
them if you can't kill them with love I
don't know what the problem is see you
open one like this see totally doesn't
matters is you're here the [__] sum
is over
you're hanging out with Joey
I just ripped this [__] open
like this look Satan's come around the
bed
people running cuz they're scared you
follow me oh my god
we're just gonna today yeah this is the
Pablo Francisco motor oil right here
Pablo Escobar I'm sorry Saint [__]
difference anyway who loves you
[__] on a Monday night September
4th
don't forget Saturday night I'm at the
ice house 7:30 working out with uncle
Joey no mud no fun no pain no gain no
hair no Rogaine you follow me we're
gonna eat another one of these men
leaders split these and then we'll do a
bong another Dino I got a special
interior this is cousin to a 24-karat
this 12 cabinets have to strengthen a
little bit more sativa I'm saying I take
care of my sugarless feed the RZA you
follow me
these two you people I hope the fourth
quarter you [__] knock it out of the
park and you know what time it is right
now it's time for a little Bangladesh
get the party started Lee you ready
start working those lungs leave that
little program it works I was like one
of those Arabs down the diamond district
you know say I still got a [__] suckers
here on a Monday night
Labor Day whatever the [__] you want to
call it
your Uncle Joe he's still [__] guy to
you I'm saying Lisa had yes you ready
sir
look at Lisa at with his Red Sox shirt
you don't give a [__] I'm saying we're
training Jack ain't nothing easy here to
church what's happening now head back
let the blood go to the back think about
what you're about to do the whole
mechanics of it sucking the weed my boom
there's a whole science to the bonnet
and uncle Joey is broken at them
everybody wants to do bong hits
everybody wants to hang out like a half
a [__] with those vapor pants and blow
clouds then we blow that cloud show
those [__] how it's done at the
coffee houses
let's [__] beat next hold it relax
look back when they go back the head hit
it like a [__] soldier
my [__] method works understand me
these are truth tested methods 37 years
doing bong hit since 84 in Aspen
Colorado and high-altitude if I don't
know what I'm talking about nobody knows
that they're [__] talking about uncle
Joey [__] with me [__] the first
year the capital to start your slow here
then the next year I'm taking you to
[__] Aspen then the Yap taken to
Mexico City hopefully by then I'll have
a passport
well [__] something will happen hands
we'll take it up to the top of the hill
we're [__] what's the little chubby
Mexican do from aka remember he got beat
up by bruh do because [__] he didn't
want to go to the top of the hill of
Mexico okay Velasquez didn't want
exactly whatever the [__] he is without
warning the wizard is here are you
[__] kidding me are you kidding me on
a Monday night we throwing [__] first
sabbatarian why cuz we want to be right
where we were last night data that never
talking just keeps walking just didn't
kill nobody the stuff I got for my main
man here look look at one the Amsterdam
Cup three years in a row there's a thief
of the year back [__] thing we say
yeah sorry about that I didn't please
say that's got me all focused look at
the eyeball of debt oh hold on one thing
[Music]
backbone let the blood go back think of
the bond hit technique it's like the
Russians in the 84 Olympics you don't
say no we don't want to be Russians you
want to be the American
[Music]
that's the one way that's the one that
killed Pablo
that's the one never top are you kidding
me or what we're making progress here
tonight who said dessert anyway formal
chocolate [__] yeah next level Monday
nights here on the church you wanna [__]
around go hang out with some other
people but if you want to see the devil
this is your best bet hanging out with
your uncle Joey tonight BAM
there you go nice and easy
nobody gets their feelings hurt oh my
god
must sleep like a [__] baby tonight
[Music]
it's over [__] said and done
[__] we don't give a [__] we're gonna
take it to the next level whether you
want to or not I'm not worried about
your agenda
I'm worried about my [__]
agenda if you get your feelings hurt
call your therapist let him deal with it
you know I'm saying but here at the
church we're trying to toughen up
America enough with the [__] excuses
enough with the webbing B's enough and
how long am I gonna be high for who
gives a [__]
take a chance Columbus did everybody
wants to have a story but nobody wants
to go to the murky waters of the
underworld you want to dick around and
[__] I was micro dosing last week who
[__] micro doses who speaks like this
Lee I'm watching you right I don't think
I didn't see you break that in half
[__] anyway yeah for you [__]
micro doses this show me for you go take
your [__] no word act overt with some
buddies at Starbucks before I micro
dosed also today get the [__] out of
micro dose this America [__] we don't
micro dose we go for the [__] jugular
that's the problem nobody wants to go
for the jugular no more everyone some
micro dose and oh my god I'm gonna go to
my therapist and get kept the [__] out
of here
tell your therapist to suck your dick
you're gonna live life on your terms
[__]
over and out understand me where's that
bong [__] pissing me off tonight [__]
getting the Cuban on a roll up that's a
package this way given who Deauville
swing by will hook you up with the
[__] back into debt
[Music]
oh yeah tremendous you know we do it
here
how you feelin papa one more banking and
we'll be tip-top Magoo but both of us
were going with try this oh [__]
[Music]
imagine putting this up your [__] ass
already
you'll be happy for - understand me
better than edible little piece of wheat
up your ass oh it's all over you won't
be able to [__] yourself to sit there
with your mouths open and drool what's
ugly say it really hasn't gotten clear
as to watch my clothes yet I watch them
on TV i watch - episode 3 - watch narcos
yeah [__] Gabriel watched him again
today either respect Li still can't
watch I can't watch until Thursday she
won't let me leave my pain I tried to
give him the [__] past and bring it
up she wasn't she she I saw I'm saying
what the [__] I told playlist let's get
the mother-in-law's getting a couple of
Colombians a couple Mexicans there on
the dream program let's cook us some
tacos and let's watch the night goes to
speak Spanish I'm saying that's how to
do it you don't want to watch the
[__] night was a white people not for
some people who matter
people wrote the date couple Mexicans
jumping over fences [__] here we go
oh yeah dildo Rizzi eatin [__]
sugarless that shit's good flavor is
that I'm happy you tuned into my
[__] yet nothing else going on
you're sitting there write your goals
for the week and I appreciate that
because it's the fourth quarter [__]
if you don't have a job in December it's
gonna be a [__] cold winter for you
then you'll be sitting there looking at
your friends showing up at Christmas
parties giving out handshakes your love
for me has just got to be real you want
me to do it you got a family I get the
podcast going before the sugar wears off
here we go [__] bond three Foley
that [__] rhymes bomb three four what's
the program
does I stick with one Joey listen God
let that family quit hit your spine get
that old air out of your stomach
ready tip your head back
there's the technique people don't tell
nobody I'm just telling you [__]
cuz I love you this is good Krav Maga
spots no idea gentlemen [__]
has one of those spots that's how they
identify you [__] you got the Christ my
god let's do this [__] we're taking this
deep back
oh yeah
there you go but the police I am making
it happen we all know [__] Leon the from
the years there he is ladies and
gentlemen that's a bad [__]
right there
no pain no gain people here at the Joe
Diaz Banga camp you too will make people
[__] turn around and go oh [__] yeah
your nostrils are tingling let me taste
some I got some weed here that'll make a
saw your toes tingle you think you got
diabetes backwards that's great let's
get this party started baby one more
pocket and then you gotta go to you he
says nobody you know youtube.com slash c
/ Joey [__] Diaz we're going
off tonight in the stand me off the deep
end
why not [__] around we'll kick it off
the fourth quarter with a [__]
Jamboree here where the [__] comes
your that anyway don't forget Saturday
night the Ice House 7:30 working out we
uncle Joey try to put this next 1/2 hour
together sort a knock I'm ready you
follow me always gonna be ready this is
not a respect for you people thank you
for supporting the church I wish you
could smell the inside of this bunk
it smells like the [__] well
[Music]
oh [__] and we're gonna end this little
prion that you know I love you me Dean
the Christ killer
we want the best B in your life don't
forget do your goals drink your water 22
push-ups and everything's gonna work out
and the goal is to be better a little
better today and what you work them
let's say you robbed somebody today for
$15 tomorrow you're gonna rob somebody
for 12 I'm saying or 17 the other way
you gonna be a little better than what
you were today and with that I'll see
you [__] 10 minutes youtube.com
/ c / Joey Diaz look at this look at
this look at this he looks like
hurricane Harvey C in ten five seconds